we're in the north sea off the coast of
scotland maneuvering in challenging
conditions to get a closer look at a
floating wind turbine
the uk gets around a quarter of its
energy from wind and these are a new
tool in the push for even more
we can see here we've got a great wind
resource a
great water depth for example to develop
offshore floating winds fixed bottom we
see limitations around the 40 meter
water depth mark
approximately
the limitation for a floating turbine is
800 meters water depth
they are a feat of engineering but only
part of the story
the uk is a world leader in wind power
but out here the reality is a little bit
more complicated than that and that's
because underneath the north sea there
are still billions of barrels of oil and
for the moment at least we are set on
extracting them
and as the climate crisis intensifies so
does the political row symbolized by an
oil field called cambo that's due to
receive final government approval for
extraction to begin
the scottish green party newly powerful
after a recent election
is outraged
the uk government's position to continue
oil and gas extraction in the north sea
to issue new licenses is not defensible
it isn't compatible with our country's
signing the paris agreement boris
johnson is being more than negligent i
think he's being downright dangerous it
is dangerous to continue on the path
that we are on millions of lives are at
risk
you thought living through a pandemic
was bad you haven't lived through the
breakdown of your biosphere yet
the uk government doesn't see it that
way
whether we export some of that oil and
gas or it's for our own use
much better to have access to that oil
and gas on our doorstep and under our
control so are you saying that the the
un and the international energy agency
are wrong when they say that new oil and
gas extraction is incompatible
with hitting global emissions targets
what i'm saying is our
the uk government's targets for net zero
by 2050 already takes into account
licensed oil and gas fields
not yet sanctioned for extraction
whatever the explanation campaigners say
this issue threatens the moral authority
of the british government
just weeks away from hosting a crucial
un climate change summit in glasgow that
is something it can ill afford to lose
hannah thomas peter sky news in the
northeast of scotland